- She's an American soccer
player and Olympic gold medalist.
She's a forward for the Portland Thorns FC
and for the US Women's
National Soccer Team.
She was the US Soccer
Female Athlete of the Year
and a FIFA World Player
of the Year Finalist.
She's Alex Morgan,
and here are her top 10 rules for success.
- I played a lot of
sports when I was younger,
and I was settled on soccer
because the '99 team really motivated me.
My dad would go out on the
soccer field with me every day
and it pushed myself in a good way
and motivated me to be the
best player I could be.
Soccer was just my thing
and I wanted to make it to
the US Women's National Team.
("Titanium" by David Guetta featuring Sia)
My favorite goal was against Italy.
I scored in probably the 93rd minute,
and I think that's one of the best parts
of my game is my finishing.
Everyone has their talent,
but it's what you do with
that talent to make it great.
I'm not worried about my future,
about what I'm going to do
in 10 years after soccer.
It's about right now,
how I can contribute
to the team's success,
how I can make sure that I'm physically
and mentally ready for each game.
So, it's really just taking it day by day
and knowing that the
future is so uncertain.
You just need to be happy
where you are right now
and just have a positive outlook on it.
So, in the morning, I
get a good night's sleep,
and in the mornings I try
and get out on here on Alki
and just kind of walk around.
It's just a really beautiful place
to kind of start your morning
and have a positive mentality
going into your day.
Yoga definitely fits into my life
in terms of preparation.
It's great just to have that sense
of feeling at ease with yourself.
Stretching is a huge part of soccer
and making sure that
you're pretty flexible,
and I just love the feeling
of kind of being alone a little bit
and being able to take
my mind off of soccer,
but at the same time, the
reason I go to yoga is
to help me succeed in soccer.
I didn't expect when I sprained my ankle
back in late October that
it would come to this,
and that was the hardest part for me,
was kind of doubting myself,
like, well, why didn't I take it easier?
Why didn't I kind of pull
myself out of training
or out of a game?
But you can't look back.
You kind of just need to look forward.
It was definitely hard,
but I feel like now
that I'm actually seeing improvement.
We just got an MRI.
It kind of helps me a little bit mentally
to be able to do a bike a
little bit, to be able to swim.
I wasn't able to do anything on crutches,
so now knowing that there's improvement,
I'm able to do some stuff,
I feel a lot more, I guess, happy.
Before every game, the key to
my preparation is consistency.
I really think that every athlete
is a little bit superstitious,
and if an athlete tells you otherwise,
I think they're lying.
So, yes, I do a couple of things.
I definitely put on my right
sock before my left sock,
and I like to take a nap at the same time
and eat the same things,
and then right before the game I like
to do a lot of mental visualization,
so I'll go in a locker
and just put on headphones
and just imagine myself in the game.
When people ask me how I
balance non-soccer stuff,
the things off the field, I think it just,
I've been more confident
in the last couple of years
with the decisions I make
and the opportunities that I'm given
and the decisions whether to
go through with it or not.
If it's authentic to who I am,
whether it's a company I'm representing
or whether it's an event I'm going to
or whether it's a photo shoot
that I've been asked to do,
I think it's just
weighing all of the things
and making sure that nothing is standing
in the way of what I do
best and what I'm here for,
and that's to play soccer.
I think there's no secret to success.
I mean, I think Abby definitely
hit the nail on the head.
It's all about hard work.
It's all about going out there
and practicing more than your opponent,
than your teammates.
It's about mentally
preparing every single day.
It's about not slacking off,
putting in that time and work.
And you can tell from Abby
that she has put in that work,
and that's, I think, the reason
that she is so successful.
But at the end of the
day, there is no secret
to why we are so successful.
I think most forwards like
to play under pressure,
or else you wouldn't play
the forward position.
But I do like that pressure.
And sometimes you don't always
succeed, and that's okay.
And as a forward you have
to find that balance.
I mean, you're going to shoot five times
and maybe you'll score
once, maybe you won't.
Maybe you'll get three
goals out of three shots.
So, it's a little unpredictable
and you've just kind of got to go with it
and have confidence in yourself.
You know, I've wanted to
be an Olympic gold medalist
since I was seven years old,
so that was a dream come true for me.
- Your role models are who, I wonder?
- My role models, I mean,
I definitely looked up
to Kristine Lilly, Mia Hamm,
Abby even in high school
and getting on the national team.
But I feel like I always wanted
to kind of make my parents proud,
and they were the two people
that came to every single game
and just were my biggest fans.
It's not what I wanted them to see.
I just wanted them to feel the passion
and I wanted them to grow that passion,
because this is exactly what I dreamed of
when I was a young kid,
when I was watching you.
This is what I dreamed off.
I'm going to cry.
- [Interviewer] You're
going to make me cry; stop.
- But just to dream big,
'cause dreams do happen.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Zephrin Pinto asked me to
for his daughter.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Alex Morgan's top 10
rules you like the best.
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.